for two years we've been given nothing
but roof cables room taxes and rights
fees
today we got football it was silver
black and surreal to be an allegiant
stadium at last
the decrepit oakland coliseum is 545
miles and light years away from where
the raiders practiced today
allegiant stadium opened its doors to
its primary tenant for the first time in
its history
there was work done but it was also a
stop and soak up the moment kind of day
the technology the jumbotrons
and the grass to quote seinfeld yes it's
real
and it's spectacular i know it's very
impressive man
the yard keepers you know for the field
have done a great job it's really fast
it's comfortable
i know a couple guys thought it was
going to be artificial turf but it
turned out to be real grass so we're
very
very excited for this i haven't seen a
stadium that looks like this
ever like you know it's blacked out
looks like a nice
limousine or blacked out h2 hummer you
know it just looks real nice and big
and aggressive and then you get inside
and then it's just beautiful i mean from
the glass i kind of walked around before
the uh
practice today and um saw like the
little party area
the you know the drinks the walk around
to the club areas and stuff man
it wasn't a a piece unturned like
everything was nice and finished well so
i'm excited